[Music]
Yes Thank
you yes Thank you for the introduction
very full hopefully Still bit
comfortable Yes So I'm also would like to
Note I'm also data Scientist
alber working on Pro Started venturing
using reinforcement learning u couple of
other initiatives as Focus  on specific
One Let Me Give You Quick overview of
Talk First Talk a little bit about Our
Food Waste
Ambition reduction Food Waste and Talk
About This Initiative that I'm working on
is Dynamic markdown I will talk about
two Different approaches but mainly
Focus on the  reinforcement Learning
part we
doale so also talk about some evaluation
methods That We use so in order To Make
sure that we also have the right
Performance And don't things Start to
break down and I will end with some
conclusions and Next steps Can you guys
see It or is it difficult Okay erm
yes So if you Maybe aware Food was is
really large Global Problem in the world
so 40 of food was in entire food chainat
Which is Just enormous If You Look at
the
Netherlands billion k
equent of billion kils of  food
was
do we
of
making so There we also have an Ambition
that we want to reduce Food was by half
in 2030 and As you can see in this plot
Here we had a bit of Bumpy start but we
slowly start systematically decreasing Food
Waste and hopefully  we land at 2030 by
half compared to
2015 ehm So yes we several initiatives eh
Where we want to reduce Food Waste and I
think it's important to Note is that you
have to Look At The entire Food chain
ehm so for us It means already with the
assortment in Stores You Want To Make
sure that your assortment is aligned
with Customer Needs you don't want to
have regional Solutions because Yes or is
not gna be optimized also how you eh how
the interior of your show Looks Like
should also be optimized Store
specifically Right so your planam is
really about where you play certain
Products should also be stored specific uh
also respect to replenishment uh You
Want To Make sure that you don't have
over forecast h because it's also going
to result Lot of food Waste ehm and  also
your order algorithm should be Smart
Right you don't want to have situation
Where You order units that don't Fit on
your shelf Because you get it in the
back You just have to store it and also
increases The Risk of Getting More Food
Waste  but also in the store itself you
can use All Kinds Of processes to
address this issue think about the
baking The Bakery ehm h we can optimiz
The baking schedule Just To Make sure
you don't bac Too Much bread Which also
gets Wasted Right And  High of subs
Ability between Products That's
Something you would like to exploit as
well eh but in this Presentation want to
talk about Dynamic
markdown and probably most of you have
seen this sticker I Guess eh so what we
basically um do already for quite some
time eh  is provide a Discount on
Products That are in the day of expiry h
Just to create this additional incentive
for customers to buy a product but since
2020 wve been Rolling Out These shelf
labels so we have this now in all the
stores and allow Us to Dynamic  Change
prices So What We Can Do Is Now That We
move Through Time we can Easily increase
The markdown That We have so we have
three Different markdown now we Start
beginning Of The Day Maybe 25 and move
to 40 and 70 Just to get this additional
More  incent Or to basically Sell your
Products you don't end up with Way at
the End of the
day er okay What's the Challenge here
then Right Yes Which markdown we set h You
Could say ok we Just use low markdown
Right we save Lot of Money  Then probably
but That's also not optimal Because you
probably be left with quite some stock
at the End of the day that didn't Sell
Right so That's not optimal also Set it
to
High get is over incentive For People
buying It Right but it's G to  be very
costly so That's like Something we would
like to
prevent So You probably Want have
something in the middle Right You slowly
increase The markdown and hopefully land
exactly approximate Closing s
Products so sort of Yes balancing act
what you have to do h on One  hand Mark
Away and the other hand you have the the
Waste eh so we have been working on that
and one of the Models That We have We
Just Want to start Simple h we just have
a rule based model and Something use a
baseline model and That's  nice about
Rules the easy to explain to understand
you can Change Them Right And You
roughly Know what's going to happen ehm
now the way this Works is that we Bas
can estimate The percent to be Sold at
Different moments In Time for given
markdown and what you  could Do Is
basically set some threshold ok I always
Want To Have This percentage that I want
to Sell Right if it goes low Below this
threshold Just increase the Mark Down
Right And also The to be s Goes up Right
that's how it works so relatively Simple
and it's already quite effective so we
already able to Sell 70 of our Products
that participate Dynamic Mark Products
on Day of
Don't alls The
nexts
lot also means Still Of Waste so we Feel
There's More For improvement and That's
The Thing with Rules of course  you can
manipulate Rules Right And try to get
better
Performance with All Kinds Of exceptions
really The Rul Just explodes really
difficult to manage so we don't feel
really Right
Direction Look at of is making decisions
markdown Basic Go Time make a Decision
The markdown Change  something in
environment then observe this
environment make Another Decision so
basically sort of control
Problem and yes Another Thing That's
That's Kind of difficult is that also if
you make a Decision do 25 or 40 you
don't know if it's good or
bad Is No supervis  it's not like
supervis Learning ok a good Decision
Decision erm we Only know if it was the
sequence of decisions if it was good or
bad at the End of the day eh B Take in
account The Sales that you have and the
Waste so The Sales is  immediate reward h
so That's Good Right If You Sell
Something That's what we want but the
way Only know at the End of the
day erm well luckily h The Things That
are important for us so The Sales and
the Mark That We have That's Something
fully observ  we can Just see that
measure that so That's That's That's
Good ehm oh It Goes quite quickly ehm
and Our trajectories h Our Decision
trajectories are also episodic so The
End Because We Only interested in the
When the store is open And at the End of
the day  they just uh det
terminate and We Can also mod ehm h we
don't need all the History eh of our Our
sales and Our previous markdown so ehm
yes we have this we can All With with
this Mark of property in mind
Yes It Makes Sense  to MOD
reinforcement n is Classic picture we
Our agent is basically our
model we make
decisions we make actions Mark we 25 40
and 70 this Change something in our env
St with customers
unc unc Yes you Don't really predict What
customers will do
ehm en  then we have an update On Our
stat and you can think about Yes The
items that you Sell The Mark that you
have but also The Demand of the product
ETC That's Kind of Things that you would
like to have in your State described eh
and you have  your reward Signal Right So
if you Sell Something you get immediate
reward and of course at the End of the
day you have the Waste
reward n d is or kan Yes It's basically
Mark Decision process what you have Here
so your
CH one to the
other
function Take  Action
State discounting
Factor
short
oks scale
ehm It's tempting Right to Just Go For
The Deep reinforcement Learning and the
most Fancy Thing ehm What you have to
keep in mind we have about Stores and we
Really Want To Have A model That Run
stab in Production Right  So if you to go
very complex solution that Just Becomes
harder and in addition to That We Just
Want To Be able also to interpret the
Performance Right so Like A Black Box
Thing be very hard to
do that We Just Want demonstrate The
potential of this Solution  to bus
stakeholders It Doesn't help very
complex Models we Said ok we Just very
Simple and Focus on discrete features
with low Cardinal We Don't many
combinations also If have continuous
variables We Just Want to discord them
making sure that the Cardinal is low  and
In The End Just not Too Many features We
Just Want to end up small stage
Space
Ok we stage Space We Could map It Out
over Time Something like this now the
Challenge is to find What's the optimal
trajectory to stage Space by maxing
reward the Challenge  is of course
Decision should you take one of
st5 40 70 That's Hard
to nal is
optimy re Bas to Figure Out Which
Decision You should take At A certain
State we use Learning so For People That
are familiar reinforcement Learning They
Know this eh and what it  basically does
we have some sort of update Rules so
when you Running your trajectories you
can update Th These values ​​and what you
basically get Is A Table Where You have
your States Which are the rows And then
The actions are the columns and basically
tells What is  the cumulative reward that
you can get At A certain State
Ching maxum value in step optim
policy
of
Con Learning
challenge
take
learn
on to unacceptable
Simply canot do that so what we have
done we actually learn Those Models
offline Because We have lots of data
Because We  have over Stores you can
imagine The size of the data That We
have and you can use that to learn your
table basically That's what we did and
even You Could Run several a The data
Just to get some
Con We Still trying to Figure out what
best  way
slow Fe ex
stace
feur
better
ehm okay so ehm I'm going quite Fast
actually he time for questions
ehm yes so One Of The challenges of
course Okay we can learn Th que tables
but We Still don't know exactly how it's
going to  perform in Production ehm so
It's a bit scary Right to put something
in Production and you don't know really
What the Performance is going to be eh
also looking ATM of policy evation ehm
so Can We Get some Sense of what the
Performance is going to  be of this new
policy that you
create the way this Works is that ok you
have your Target policy That's your new
policy By One And then given The data of
some Behavior policy That's already
something that has been running in
Production Can We use that data to
evaluate this new
policy There several methods that you
can
use One I think simp One is We all data
We Could learn a Mark of Decision
process If want Right Basic comes down
to figuring out what are transition
probabilities this P head and what is
our reward function  So what's the reward
That We Get In A certain State If Take A
certain
Action and we could Simple initial
starting values ​​And then Run tror on
this on this M and we Sense of cul re
of course make estimates of P R are
accurate Because if not you  get a bias
in this estimate of
course we have lots of data prob for us
work as
well low vari quite
nice Meth That You Could use is based on
important sampling and what you do There
You Look at the ratio of
Production Do
Is is
muls that  of
this you have a very big difference in
Those Action probabilities this Row is
gna be huge Right so so you can get Prom
with stability in Those estimates eh and
the really have PR with curs of Horizon
So if you have very Long trajectories
ehm yes you  get really stability
issues Yes The Method That We opt for ehm
is ehm Basic Combination of these Two
Two methods ehm so get best of both
worlds in the Sense so There asymptotic
unbiased
and if One either one of these are
correctly specified then you ensure
consistency and  a Tent very low low
variance ehm although I think we can
also get away with the direct Method eh
but it was an interesting approach
ehm and it seems to be working
relatively
well So how does this work then exactly
so we have Our data from
eh Behavior  policy from the data but
instead of Looking At The actions of
your Behavior policy Want To Look at the
Target actions and estimate what is the
award SO cumul of your Behavior and your
Target is not going to Be Different
Right
eh So how does this work exactly  So
basically yes sort of recursive
update Formula and What's important to
do that First is to estimate your re
function based on the values ​​Behavior eh
policy ehm a Next Step would like to do
is ok what is now the State value under
this
Target policy ehm For  The Different
State that by the Behavior policy and You
just multiply that with the eh die
Target Action probabilities Times The
estimated reward function and Just Sum
that
up nou dis is B stochastic expected
Sing ra two things coming Together then
get new estimate can Run this Formula
Again implemented this part I was aare
was nice library available
poar nice impl yourself also Force
yourself to really understand These
Things but implement this I did have
some issues with stability and it's
mainly due to this Row value um and One
Way of dealing that with that  something
I've seen in Research papers of clipping
These estimates So you approximately
know what the reward values ​​It can Take
Right So if it's really outside of this
Range You Could Just clip These clip
values ​​Thing also work very well was
just normalizing this R When  You comp In
This R Just normalizing It Just behav
Way Better eh so That's also Another
thing you can you can
Try now If You Look at all policy
evaluation So What you basically doing
is counter factual reasoning so sort of
cal inference eh and we know with  CA
inference all these underlying
assumptions that you have to satisfy and
one of these is the positivity
assumption
erhm yes Basic says that the action that
you take in Target policy also in
Behavior policy Because if AC Never
happen in practice you don't know what
the  reward is
right so really When using Kind of
Things You really Have To Look at the
support of the actions that you have in
your Target policy What happens in
Production Because otherwise
you just get a bias in your estimate I
did some
experiments Really Going up Goes
Down
yeah implementing This I actually us a
couple of these open source tooling I
Just Want to mention them Here since by
data so it's good to have some open
source tooling eh and I think This one
is quite Nice I Wasn't aware of This one
When I Started working on this but I
looked into This one It Looks really really
promising so I don't know if
Somebody Else has Experience with that I
Would love to hear
that I can actually confirm that Pol is
really Fast That's nice and also  really
like this Gymnasium Library to test your
assumption you can All Kinds Of
environments in there that you can
use so Just developing this that really
helps to yes test All Kinds Of
assumptions that you
have Okay ehm So This off policy
evaluation really helps to determine Okay
Where Are You With your Performance
Right Keeping in mind That You could
have a bias in Those estimates but it
does help you get some feedback About It
eh but of course In The End Just Run
Production and see what the Performance
going to be so We Do  Run Ab experiments
for all Our BS eh what is off policy
elation basically helps Us determine
what kind of traffic you are going to assign
to this New Model
eh If You are bit unsure about the
Performance you bit conservative You
just lower this percentage a bit more
instead of having a High number
There and basically what we do We always
generally to competing Models ehm That
We Set Up In An experiment but in
addition to That We always have the
baseline model Because We always want to
compare to that uh and we have some
expiration Models Running as well and
These Things are like having Always 25
per Always 40 or Always 70 So if you
live near a Store that has this model
then You're Lucky
ehm but it also helps to determine What
the per to be Sold is with  this Kind of
data So You have just trajectories Where
You Don't Change The
Mar Just very helpful we do some
significant testing And then we can
Basic deter ok Which model out performs
the other And then we work on a new one
and we set in  the next experiment sort
of tournament
setup B to try to
optimize the Models That We have so we
start we have a lot of ideas of
experiment This Is In The End The Way To
Meure
to ehm yes I'm Yes Right Bit Of Time left
ehm  yes so conclusions
erm yes so I think we are on the right
track so refor seems to be very nice Fit
for this Type of Problem and initial
Performance show some interesting
eh Promise so we really would like to
continue with this I think it's
important to a  baseline model When doing
These Things that understand and compare
Again you know where you are Performance
I think this on an interesting thing to
get some Feeling of of what the
Performance is going to be but Keeping
in
mind assumption that you need and
Different Matters Because You  Can have
issues with
stability and Yes You Can have bias in
estim bit careful using
Things complicate things ehm h that can
be The Next Step eh and That's actually
also what we Thinking about because this
Tab Co It's Not scalable So if you want
to add features  to it Yes Just explodes
the combinations of States going to get
So You Rather have some some function
representing that but that also has Own
challenges and what I already mentioned
Before we Really Want to focus also on
adding new assortment ehm to Yes to this
to D  markdown erm and even like
Products that Go Out Of assortment So It
Doesn't even have to be Food so it's not
really fits in foodway Story anymore but
Still It is Technique that you can apply
to other things as well
erm yes so we have  a bit more time left
Which is Nice I Guess so Thank
you some time Indeed for questions if
you have Any questions please take the
microphone and speak into it so we can
record your question
What are the inputs that you give to the
model When It's operational  in the
store
ex
items current Mar
that also we
have forecasting teams we Yes The
forecast of Products I do have to make a
Side Note there because this forecast is
about not Dynamic markdown Products
Right so Just
normal Products Bas that not on the day
of expiry  so I do Believe There is a
difference in Demand and depends B on
the Type of Customer That a lot of
customers Just Want to take the product
with the longest expiration date instead
of the
Isy Price elas
features we to keep it
small is BIC observation that  Goes Into
The Next iteration Model based on that
determine be Next
Action Yeah I was wondering At what
level Are You predicting At individual
product or group of Products or Yes we
generic model so we have looked into
this but the Problem that you get if you
going  to have Store specific or even
product specific Models then you really
Need lots of data ok we do have a lot of
data but then That's really not level I
think we can slowly move There we
already look like Look
at characteristics of Stores That are
very similar
So you can go a bit Deeper already we
More specific Models but We recently
Started exploring this Area that would
really be Next Step That We would like
to Explore but definitely interesting to
go at the lower level Where You can
really pick up some specific Dynamics of
this Problem
Yes When c the
value How
we Haven really explored this Area
yet that Would Be really something that
we have to Look Into Our Main Focus was
can we run such reinforcement Learning
model in Production And at
scale Yes
little
some we Selection
per but I  Would really see that Next
Step and we Deeper in Type of
Models work l compy also Need get buy from
stakeholders basically this
Promise and Can We continue working on
this stage of demonstrate this potential
Don't Get Me Wrong It's Still very
impressive finally something useful  in
the
Thank It Said that you trained the model
for two weeks or More Which Would Be 14
episodes or
More usually in literature you can see
that they train The model for one or two
Million Time steps would two weeks or
More sufficient mod
Long
experiments we  R The experiments for
weeks actually we learn The Models we
Take quite A Rich data
eh yes actually you get problems with
Running Times because That's The Thing
with belman equation you canot do it in
Factor Way so just have to do all these
iter and Just takes
Forever It also helps not very l stage
Space Because you have to wait Forever
this thing conges ehm wat eh
yes interesting to move More to the value
function approximations I think that
Would Be opens up the Door To More
possibilities definitely in practice so
We Do use  a larger larger date and it
also helps a lot That We have These
Exploration Models So This fix markdown
Models and we have the date of the rule
Bas model We Just combine All These
Things Because You Just Want To Make
sure that you Explore most of stage
Right We Still see that not explored So
You Can can imagine like 70 at the
beginning of the day That's not G be
explored that much because That's not
very optimal thing you want to do and
very
expensive so There Is Where You See in
the State Space  that Yes It's Less
explored Another
Question How do you Handle The
Exploration
exploitation Yes so we Now so what we
since We Do offline Learning we actually
a separate that does Only expiration
instead of
Explore explo and also The Reason that
That We Can also Meure pure Performance
having a
greedy
policy so that also helps Just to see ok
Where with the
Performance And then we have Dedicated
Models to do the Exploration part and we
then use this data in the offline so we
also Don't learn we run the model also
One Of  The Things that to keep in mind
because Do Learning online Yes this thing
starts Learning Okay What's What's the
Performance going to be right you get
new policies constantly Right so That's
also a little bit scary also for
stakeholders say don't like that very
much so  so It's probably better just
have fixed And then you know ok That's
The Performance that we measured in the
ope al you can also measure of course
when you do More Exploration that of
course That's as Possible
ehm but Yes then things behave much Nicer
and uh yes  Just to Play it safe basically
yes That's very interesting thank you thank
you Thanks for Presentation I'm really
impressed with your approach and I can
imagine How big should be your data Just
I'm Curious about the complexity of your
model Because You mention There  are Lot
of estates that you have so Out Of The
Curiosity How many did Explore Yes
Remember exactly is like
Our
level I think that makes Sense not be
very big difference
Mark minutes
Hour that
slif the Problem basically
specification
Fe unable
notable we some we have to  move into
value function approx ok interesting
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
wies